Herkese merhaba
genelde bugün sosyal sorumluluk
projeleri dinliyoruz Benimki teknoloji
konuşması olacak
Ben de TED konuşma videolarını
dinlemekten büyük zevk alan biriyim
Hatta Geçtiğimiz günlerde bir tane
izliyorum konuşmacı kendisi dalgındır
bir arkadaşım büyük sunumlarda
heyecanlanmamak için
seyircilere çıplak hayal etmemi
öneriyordu
şimdi fark ediyorum ki pek iyi bir fikir
değilmiş
hayallerinizi gerçeğe dönüştürmek ister
miydiniz onlara dokunmak onları
hissetmek ve bunun hiç olmadığı kadar
kolay olduğunu söylesem size Evet bu
artık 3D yazıcılar sayesinde Mümkün
olacak
bu arkamda görmüş olduğunuz bir 3D
Yazıcı
3D yazıcılar bir çoğunuz şaşırabilir ama
ilk 1984 yılında icat ediliyor Peki
neden onca süre geçtikten sonra popüler
Kralı oluyorlar tren konuluyorlar Bunun
cevabı ise şu an 1984 yılında icat
edilen 3D yazıcılar
ilk patenti 1987'de alınıyor 20 yıllık
bir aradan sonra yani 2007'de bu
patenler düşüyor bunun sonucunda ise
binlerce kişi 3D yazıcılar üzerinde
çalışmaya başlıyorlar ve bu yaptıkları
çalışmaları birbirleriyle
paylaşıyorlardı
Örneğin ben 3D Yazıcı geliştiriyorum
konut tüm mekanik elektronik ve
yazılımsal kompone yerine internette
paylaşıyorum oradan arkadaşım indiriyor
indirdikten sonra
kontrol ediyor diyor ki Tamam mekaniği
yazılımı diye Fakat bunun elektronik
kartı olmamış değiştiriyor atla alt
ediyor oradan buraya diğer arkadaşım ona
da kontrol ediyor ama elektronik kartı
olmuş yazılımı da tamam ama diyor Bunun
mekanik problemleri var mekanik
problemlerini gideriyor ve tekrar
yüklüyor bunun sonucunda kartopu gibi
büyüyen bir etki ile 3D yazıcıların
arkasında ciddi bir bilgi birikimi ve
komedi dolaşıyor ve bunun sonucunda ise
3D yazacak dünyada Trend konu oluyor
Tabi bu bunun arkasındaki yatan en büyük
sebeplerden biri ise paylaşmayı seven
insanların yaralanması tabi Burada
dijital dünyanın
olanağı da unutmamak gerekiyor
geçtiğimiz 20 yılda dijital dünyada bir
devrim yaşandığını görüyoruz
bunu devrenin sonucunda ise İnternetten
yemek siparişi verir olduk alışverişimiz
internetten yapar olduk sosyal medya
olarak adlandırılan bir medya kanalı
ortaya çıktı bilgiye ulaşamıyor O da
paylaşmak hiç olmadı kadar kolaylaştı
dünya ise Şimdi yeni bir
bir dev Devrim ise
bu sefer dijital dünyada olmayacak
atomların dünyasına yani Gerçek dünya da
olacak
dijital devrimde yaşanan dijital dünyada
yaşanan devrimle artık bilgisayarınızda
bir proje veya obje tasarlamak oldukça
basit bunun için birçok ücretsiz çoğul
var ve 3D yazıcılar ise Bilgisayar
ortamında tasarladığımız Bu proje
ödevinizi çok kısa sürede ve çok ucuza
hayata geçirmenize olanak sağlıyor
Eğer geçen gün ucuzlayan fiyatları ve
ulaşması kadar 3D yazıcılar ise tüm
dünyada daha ulaşılabilir oluyor bu ise
şu anlama geliyor artık üretim
Fabrikalardan evlere taşınıyor yani
sizin artık fikrinizde hayata geçirmek
için ciddi bir yatırıma ihtiyacınız yok
ya da bir fabrikaya ihtiyacınız yok
bunun için Tek ihtiyacınız olan şey bir
3D yazıcı'ya sahip olan sese
ulaşabiliyor olmanız
bu ise tüm dünyada şöyle adlandırılıyor
üretim Artık
demokratikleşiyor bize hikayemizde tam
olarak burada başlıyor
bundan 11 ay önce Bahçeşehir
Üniversitesi Yani bu üniversitede bu
üniversitenin Mekatronik
mühendisliğinden mezun oldum bu
fotoğrafta Yanılmıyorsam bir yıl
öncesine ait 3 metrekarelik bir alan
zemin kat
Buğra ışıkçı başı
İlker
bir kavram kar başladı içerisinde
Samsung monitör kutusunun üzerinde
Microsoft inek sensöre bağlı Apple
bilgisayar
diğer arkadaş giderek 3D tarama yapmaya
çalışıyoruz
üniversite Yolları içerisinde tabi
arayış içerisinde idim ben mezun
olduktan sonra ne yapmalıyım konusunda
Buna cevap bulabilmek için benim neyin
mutlu ettiğimde araştırmaya başladım ve
fark ettim ki ben insanların hayatlarını
kolaylaştırmayı ve katma değer yaratmayı
seviyorum bunun adıysa benim tarafıma
girişimcilik Yani ben bir girişimci
olmalıydım bunun için kitaplar okudum
dersler aldım
kurumsal şirketlerde ve startuplarda
çalıştım Kendimi geliştirdim Yani doğru
zaman ve doğru yer geldiğinde hazır
olmak için
3D yazıcılarda ilk tanıştığım günse
farkettim ki ben bu alanda girişim
yapmalıydım ve Ocak 2015 ve 12 Ocak
Hatta 4 ay oldu bir yatırım alarak Buğra
aksever ve İlker varlığıyla üç Durağı
kurduk
3 durak kişilerin fikirlerini Hayata
dönüştürdükleri bir 3D Yazıcı Merkezi
burada projenizde üç boyutlu
modellenmesinden seri üretime kadar
geçen süreçte birçok servis
alabiliyorsunuz bunun yanında 3D Yazıcı
3d tarayıcı gibi teknolojileri
deneyimleyebiliyorsunuz
üst tarafta sadece teknolojileri
görmekle kalmayıp geleceğin üretim
şeklinde de Tanık olabiliyorsunuz
tabi Burada tüm dünyada olduğu gibi
Türkiye'de bir evlilik oldukça az
genelde yaşadığımız en büyük problem ise
klasik printerlarla kredi olarak kıyas
veya kalp karıştırılıyor olması Örneğin
Geçenlerde Yaşadığımız bir örneği
anlatayım
biri koşar adım içeriye girdi baskı
yapıyor musunuz dedi Ben içeride
oturuyorum bizim takımdan bir arkadaş
çıktı yapıyoruz dedi yani 10-15 sayfa
çıktı bu arada bunu alabilir miyiz dedi
beyefendi hani biz baskı yapıyoruz ama
onun için özellikle
Onlar daha iyi yardımcı olur
Tamam oraya gideyim de siz ne
yapıyorsunuz burada dedi biz dedi üç
boyutlu baskı yapıyoruz ya tamam 3
boyutlu olsun
yeni örnekler verir bazıları da
teknolojiyi doğru anlıyor ama yanlış
amaçlarla kullanmak istiyor bunu hiç
anlatmıyorum
Tabii 3D yazıcıların kullanım alanları
bir model tasarlayayım ve bunu
ürettiğinden ibaret değil çok farklı
alanlarda çok büyük avantajlar sunuyor
Örneğin bu fotoğraf
Uluslararası Uzay istasyonundan
bir anahtara ihtiyacı oluyor ve bu
anahtar istasyonda yok bunun için
Normalde yapılan şey bir sonraki
ihtimali beklenmesi bu ise bazen aylar
Bazen ise yıllar alan bir süreç
fakat
istasyonda bir 3D Yazıcı var veda ise
dünyada belli oranın ihtiyacı olduğu
objeyi hemen tasarlıyor e-mail olarak
modeli gönderiyor Benim numaram ise
saatler içerisinde öğretiyor
oluyor bu sadece Zamandan tasarruf
sağlamıyor aynı zamanda ciddi bir
maliyetin önüne geçiyor
buradan dünyada uzaya bir kilogram bile
onca taşımanın ciddi maliyetleri var
ve NASA bu gibi benzer modelleri şu an
internete ücretsiz şekilde paylaşmaya
başladı Mesela bu elimde görmüş
olduğunuz da bmw'ın tuttuğu anahtarla
aynısı sizin de bir 3D yazacağınız varsa
ulaşabiliyorsanız benzer modelleri
indirip kullanabiliyorsunuz bu tek parça
çıktı ve şu an çalışma çalışabilir yani
bunun yanında uzun vadede ise uzayda
üstler burada olmasak bile anlıyor uzay
işçileri ve burada
da olacak Yani dünyada hocalar oraya
taşınmayacak direkt üretim orada da
gerçekleştirilecek
bunun yanında 3D yazıcıların sunduğu en
büyük avantajlardan biri ise
kişiselleştirilebilir yani kişiye özel
üretimi olarak sağlaması
gelecekte kişiler firmaların onları
sunduğu seçenekler arasında en
beğendikleri öyle değil kendi
isteklerini de orada tutsunda
kişiselleştirdikleri ürün satın
alacaklar
Bununla ilgili ikinci endüstriyel devr
şöyle diyor
Yani insanlar diyor siyah olduğu sürece
istediği renkte araba satın alabilirler
bu aslında şunu demek Ben siyah
satıyorum Sen istersen mavi almak iste
artık gelecekte firmalar
otomobillerin bazı parçalarını aynı gibi
internete ücretsiz olarak paylaştıracak
paylaşacaklar Press o modelleri indirip
kişiselleştirip 3D yazar üretip
kullanabileceksiniz
tabi 3D yazıcılar Sadece bu Mühendislik
uygulamaları Mühendislik alanında
uygulamalar yok birçok farklı site orada
kullanılıyor Bunlardan en önemlisi de
meraklı Medikal sektör
Medikal sektörde şu an doku ve organ
basan 3D yazıcıların üzerinde
çalışıyorlar
biliyorsunuz dünyada organ nakliye
bekleyen birçok hasta var ve buradaki en
büyük problem uygun organın bulunması
bir başlı başına bir problem
bulunduğunda ise doku uyuşmazlığı
olasılığı oldukça yüksek 3D yazıcılar
ise bunun
bu iki problemini ortadan kaldırıyor Siz
buradaki makinalarda zaten üretimi
ihtiyaç duydunuz organı kendi
hücrenizden veya kök hücrenizden
üretiyorlar
Böylece
Siz de her problemin üstesinden gelmiş
oluyorsunuz Örneğin 2002 yılında
Amerikalı bir şirket
laboratuvar ortamda 3 ay yaşayan bir
böbrek yürekte yazıcı ile
bunun yanında
güzel çalışmalar var bir Üniversitede 3
'te aort damarı üretildi Bunun nedeni
ise ağır damarı Vücuttaki en büyük damar
ve başka bir damarların yerini
değiştirmeniz mümkün değil
bunun yanında implant tarafında da
oldukça kullanılıyor yani Örneğin
kafatasının bir bölüm hasar almış
kişinin 3 boyutlu tarayıcı ile kapanır
modeli elde ediyor ve hasarlı bölgeye 3D
yazıcı ile bir uyumlu materyal
yerleştiriliyor
bir diğer uygulaması ise 3D yazıcıların
bu ise ensest getirelim
biliyorsunuz
Medikal ticari Pr
otezi ve bunları fiyatları 10 binlerce
lira merteb
eleri fakat bir üç boyutlu yazıcı
ile
protezeri evde dolardan daha ucuza mal
edebilirsiniz
O çocuğun istediği film karakterinde ya
da çizgi roman karakterinde oluyor yani
o çocuğa özel
ve yine o çocuğun kol yapısına engel
yapısına özel olarak
biz bunun için açıkçası Türkiye'de
bunu öncelerinden olmak istedik
vakıfların kapılarını Çaldık özel
hastanelerle görüştük Fakat ne yazık ki
bir yol kat edemedik
bizim elimizde
bugün paylaşmak istiyoruz ve yardımcı
olmak istiyoruz Eğer Sizler arasında Bu
konuda bize yardımcı olunabilecek olan
varsa lütfen benimle iletişime geçsin
dijital dünyada bir devrim yaşandığından
bahsetmiştim ve bu Devrim hayatımızda
çok şey değiştirdi fakat Bizler ise
gerçek dünyada yaşıyoruz orada nefes
alıyor orada işe gidiyoruz
ve Dijital Dünya sadece hayatınızı
ticari alanı %10'unu oluşturuyor
ve burada yaşanacak yani gerçek dünyada
yaşanacak bir devrim ise hayatımızı
baştan sona değiştirecek bizim çok
sevdiğimiz bir söz var Bu da interneti
var indi aydınlardayız hem de bu arada
çay önce geldim Çok teşekkürler
dinlediğiniz için sağ